welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid every day of your life you see in
here numbers two dollars and fifty cents
for a dozen bagels monthly rent tuning
your radio station speed limit signs the
mileage on your car the news says the
u.s. national debt is 17 trillion
dollars they're unavoidable some of them
we don't have much trouble with others
seem almost incomprehensible what's the
biggest number you think you can
understand a hundred a thousand I think
I could probably get ten thousand all
lies if those numbers are money you
might be able to comprehend how much it
could buy you but that doesn't mean
you're comprehending the actual number
the human brain has a limited it's a lot
lower than you might think I'd like to
propose something the biggest number a
human being is truly capable of
comprehending five yep I said five one
two three four five that's it that's
ridiculous I can get at least 10 nope
that's two groups of five in fact think
of your close group of friends and I
mean the really close ones the ones you
keep in your thoughts on a daily basis
how many are there about five how about
you're significantly close family how
many items can you remember to get at
the store without writing a list you
just can't keep the rest in your head
whether it's people items or tasks it
doesn't matter you just forget them
still think I'm crazy
yep well I am but that doesn't make me
wrong and I could prove it to you try to
picture ten marbles in your mind it
probably looks something like this there
you go with two groups of five again you
can't comprehend 10 without groups now
try a hundred marbles can you guarantee
me that there are exactly 100 marbles
without grouping them together probably
not so let's forget about trying a
thousand just to drill this home I'm
gonna flash pictures of dots on the
screen but I'm gonna do it for a short
enough amount of time that you can't
just sit there and count them no pausing
the video cheaters all I want you to do
is tell me how many there are ready got
a number there were six still think you
got it without grouping okay so maybe
you did that one cuz I said about five
how about this one got a number that was
eight let's try one a little harder I'd
be willing to bet that none of you got
that one it was fifteen that was twenty
three the only way you were gonna get
that one is if I did this four groups of
five and then a group of three or how
about this one
that was fifty
getting the picture we have to do groups
to comprehend large numbers but even
that has its limitations for example if
you wanted to comprehend 100 at a glance
there would have to be 4 groups of 5
groups of 5 having groups of group
starts to stretch our minds a little too
far there's only one way we could hope
to work with numbers in the millions and
that's thinking of them abstractly with
arithmetic and algebra trying to
comprehend a 17 trillion dollar national
debt would just make anyone's head
explode in science we deal with really
big numbers all the time so knowing how
to do math is an essential skill this
limitation of 5 should also be something
to consider when you're working in
groups in any city an organization could
never hope to organize the schedules or
duties of its members without writing
them down
it's amazing the 535 member Congress can
get anything done oh wait they don't so
what was the biggest number you thought
you could comprehend let us know in the
comments and until next time remember
it's okay to be a little crazy oh and I
almost forgot
paint green did a vlogbrothers video
about big numbers you guys should check
it out there's a link in the description
do it